all right
that was good it's actually zervay no
it's not I'm kidding it's serve you had
it right
[Laughter]
all right awesome well hi everybody I
think we have uh the smallest room but
the highest uh IQ to cubic centimeter
ratio of uh of any room in the in the
conference at this point so that's good
news
uh I'm Greg Michaelson
um I came from a company called Data
robot anybody familiar with data robot
at all yeah uh I joined in 2015. it was
a different world back in 2015. uh
people were still sort of moving to the
cloud
and uh everybody was convinced that the
citizen data scientists would be sort of
taking over yeah I've never actually
seen a citizen data scientist except in
grainy photos in the woods you know
which is uh which is supposed to be a
joke
uh
uh but I joined a company called zurf
and we're looking at the data science
development experience so I'm going to
do something profoundly unwise in this
talk and that is talk about how data
scientists do things which you know
there's a there's a pretty wide uh
spectrum of data scientists I'm
somewhere in the middle of that Spectrum
you've got guys on one end that go well
I do everything in Vim uh because that's
how I code that's how that's how intense
I am as an engineer and then you've got
other people that are like oh I use data
robot and I never touch my keyboard I
always use my mouse to do my data
science so there's like a spectrum of of
people so when I generalize uh just
think the worst of me but don't say it
out loud and then we'll get along
so
um Jupiter notebooks how many of you
have ever used the Jupiter notebook
before yes my people I dreamed that I
would I would ask that question and no
hands would go up and then I'd be I'd be
like well
funny enough let's talk about Jupiter
notebooks
um so I'm gonna give you four reasons
why I think there are significant
problems with Jupiter notebooks and
maybe we can think a little bit about
how we might fix those uh it's a bit
self-serving because serve is designed
to fix all those problems but I'm not
going to talk about Zorb at all well I
may be a little but I'm not it's not a
sales pitch so if you want to find out
about Zorb just come to our booth and
we'll we will happily deliver the sales
page even though we don't actually have
a product to sell yet we don't launch
until
May so okay so uh that is Fernando Perez
the guy who invented Jupiter notebooks
back 20 years ago or so at Berkeley they
were called IPython notebooks back then
and certainly there have been lots of
contributors over the years to them uh
but the quote is fascinating he said I
thought maybe I could build a small tool
that would make that process of running
a bit of code maybe plotting visualizing
some data continuing to write code dot
dot dot a bit easier and so he sort of
betrays the reason that he developed
these notebooks in the first place isn't
that this to be a scratch Pad a place to
go and kind of explore and and do
interesting things but that's also one
of the big downfalls of notebooks when
you ask a data scientist what tool stack
do you use most of the time they'll say
well I like notebooks no books are
really interesting they they're great
for exploratory analysis but if I'm
doing anything really serious then I go
to spider or vs code or pycharm or some
scripting environment where I can you
know write something that will actually
not fall over as soon as something goes
wrong with it so a little illustration
here's a screenshot of a Jupiter
notebook I set a variable a equal to one
and then I add one to it and I get eight
who knows who knows my devious trick
how did I do it
I ran it a bunch of times yeah that's
the problem with jupyter notebooks is
that or the one of the main problems is
that they just sort of run code
sequentially behind the scenes but you
can actually run the cells in any order
you want so if you find somebody's
notebook from grad school or something
it'll say there'll be a comment that
says run this cell after you one run the
one eight cells later otherwise you'll
get weird results right so these
notebooks were designed to operate as
scratch pads and that's why all of them
have this restart the kernel button
which I was thinking about this last
night and I was I was trying to imagine
the
uh the circumstances that gave rise to
that button because surely when Fernando
Perez started building Jupiter notebooks
there was no restart kernel button on
the toolbar like it can't possibly have
been his intention to build that to
build that button what happened was
version 1.0 came out and his notebook
got into bad State and he said oh
he doesn't want to have to kill terminal
and then restart the notebook he was so
he needed a restart kernel button that's
how that button came about and so if you
use any notebook environment anywhere
whether it's Jupiter or databricks or
hex or Google collab or any notebook
environment out there they all have this
button even though if you set out today
to design a notebook environment
there's no way that you would create
that button it's a sign of an
architectural problem that notebooks
were designed to be a scratch Pad type
environments for academics and not
serious tools used to build
machine learning in business
make sense
okay cool number two the underlying
architecture of notebooks is really
quite obsolete this is kind of how
people well here here I go generalizing
how data scientists do data science you
download your data locally you open it
up in a Jupiter notebook hopefully you
don't win the lottery so that all of
your work goes away or you know
hopefully you don't lose power and you
lose everything and so on and then you
have email collaboration where you're
like I mean you can't you can't manage a
Jupiter notebook in GitHub right because
it just doesn't work so you end up doing
things like slacking files to each other
like notebook files to each other and
then the people go to change all the
paths you know it's like it's crazy
because it's a it's an obsolete
architecture I was working with Health
and Human Services part of the US
government during covid
and we had a project
where we were trying to help with the
vaccine trials the coveted vaccine
trials I didn't know this but it turns
out that when you run a vaccine trial
the secret to a successful vaccine trial
is getting enough people in there that
actually get sick
because what they do it's double blind
study and once you have enough sick
people you can measure a statistically
significant difference between the
people who got the vaccine and the
people who who got the placebo well in
the U.S people who aren't White
don't participate in clinical trials
because in the U.S history there's a lot
of sort of unsavory
things that happened in medical
experimentation and stuff with minority
groups so it's sort of out of the
culture of minority groups to
participate in those kinds of Trials
well it also happens that minority
groups in the U.S for covid were being
infected at a much higher rate which
means that if you're conducting a
vaccine trial the more a diverse group
of people you can involve in that study
the more quickly the study will complete
and the faster your vaccine gets
implemented right or gets approved by
the FDA so literally the fewer black
people that you enroll in your study the
more people die of covid because your
vaccine didn't get released in time to
save him and at that point there were
thousands of people dying every day to
covet so it was really important to get
people involved so we're working like 18
20 hours a day trying to build a
simulation to talk about okay you should
Target these neighborhoods and you
should advertise here and these are the
things you can do and we think it'll
shorten your your uh your your trial by
two weeks or three weeks or four weeks
or whatever it might be
we were working in notebooks as you do
and we were doing these things emailing
Sly uh notebook files back and forth and
slacking files and who's got the latest
version of The Notebook and okay we're
going to sleep in America and the German
team is waking up and send everybody
send them the latest notebooks it was
insane it's completely insane so what do
you need uh skip that slide for a second
you need a cloud-based notebook that's
what you need and so there's actually
tons of these that have have come around
I think hex is the latest one they've
raised I think 70 million dollars or
something in in funds uh you know
they're going really well this super
slick interface hexes is collaborative
Google collab is is
free ish
databricks is horrifying uh data Lord
there's lots and lots to ignore the
deserve column the deserve slides so we
of course have to have a check box in
every check mark in every box but this
is sort of table Stakes for the type of
uh of notebook that is getting created
today all of these different features
that that sort of exist over here but
what you'll notice is that
the scratch Pad nature of notebooks if
you put them online then let lots of
people log into the same notebook at the
same time so that lots of people can run
different cells inside the notebook all
at the same time it actually makes the
problem significantly worse than if you
were just working locally and emailing
files back and forth because a
collaborative notebook in the cloud
that's still based on that scratch Pad
architecture
gets in a bad State significantly more
often than if you were working
separately and communicating uh like
they did back in 1990 right
uh so this actually let me jump back
here
another example of the obsolete
architecture of these things is that
they are all single threaded uh every
every day data science development
environment that I've worked in uh from
SAS to our studio to uh you know Jupiter
if once you started thinking you either
need to open up another tab or you know
get you pull out your laptop or your
other laptop and start working on that
my first job was in a bank in the U.S
and we were doing you know this is like
years and years ago and we were running
SAS and it turns out if you open two SAS
sessions on the same computer that weird
stuff starts to happen they interact and
really like uh
unexpected ways so you have
non-repeatable bugs and such so I
actually had two towers that I was
running two computers with two monitors
and two keyboards and two mice and my
biggest problem was accidentally
switching the mice you know so I I
grabbed a mouse and and where is my
mouth you know that sort of thing
everything still works that way right
like Jupiter is still single threaded
you I when I when I run in those
environments I've got like eight tabs
open across the top and it's different
notebooks and you can tell by the little
icon in the tab whether whether or not
it's still thinking you know what I mean
so you're you're like oh that one's done
and the whole work there
it's crazy right why can't we have an
environment where I can run multiple
things all at the same time
that's that's another example of the
obsolete
architecture of notebooks
okay third copy and pasting everywhere
right what is the shortcut key for cut
copy and paste
does anybody not know off the top of
their heads the shortcut key for cut
copy and paste
it's control
X could exactly everyone knows why do we
know because you do it a thousand times
a day right uh how about this one
who anybody work on a Mac
shortcut key for a screenshot
yeah I don't even know the keys it's
just that that's that's how you do it
right command shift three and four yeah
everybody knows why because you take
these things all the time right so you
finish all your work you've got your
beautiful Jupiter notebook you got your
graphics all laid out and they're
perfect just like you like them and then
you open up PowerPoint and you command
shift three and you drag the thing and
you paste it into the PowerPoint slide
and everybody's happy until the data
changes or somebody asks a question and
then you have to remake every slide and
change every number and redo all the
screenshots and everything we know these
shortcut keys because
the whole ecosystem is built around
copying pasting things into other
environments right PowerPoint and uh for
production I mean most data scientists
are not machine learning Engineers right
who are like used to building construct
like production type pipelines and so
what will happen is the engineers end up
copy and pasting sections out of
notebooks into some production
environment like airflow or whatever so
that the code will actually run and be
you know usable in some kind of a real
environment so whether you're the data
scientist trying to show your results or
whether you're the software engineer the
poor software engineer who has to clean
up after uh hacks like me that are not
good coders but still write code to do
data science
you end up doing a ton of copy and
pasting and so you memorize all the
shortcut keys
okay number four automation is built for
the wrong people
um so I mentioned at the top that I was
that I came from data robot
I joined there in 2015. like I said uh
the the great hope back then was the
citizen data scientist who we were we
were going to empower to build machine
learning models by abstracting away all
the technical bits and so all they would
have to do is drag in a data file and
the tools would magically transform the
data standardize it take care of all the
missing values encode all your
categoricals do your embeddings for any
text variables automatically try all the
different kinds of models and then give
you a model that oh by the way it's also
a deployment and so you can do
everything with all you have to do is
drag in the data set and you're done
right the cool thing is that the tech
can actually do it like the machine the
automl software is real good the problem
is the the business analysts can't
comprehend it so I was a data robot we
actually hired a hundred former McKinsey
people and we assigned them the task of
putting together what we call use case
workshops to go around from customer to
customer to try and help them figure out
reasons to use our software at data
robot is that crazy or what it's like
automl somehow became a solution in
search of a problem
and that's that's the fact but in
reality
well and what happened was that data
robot sort of gave rise to all of these
GUI based machine learning tools like
your alteryx and your your data IQs and
your you know these kinds of tools that
are like Mouse tools you know this is
the war war between the machines and
those are kind of coming up and what you
see with companies like that is that
their customer net retention tends to be
really poor because it's easy to sell AI
tools but it's hard to get non-data
scientists to adopt those tools if
they're the actual users because they
don't really know what they're for
so the keyboard is winning in my opinion
because the only people who are actually
getting value out of machine learning
are the people who are able to code and
use it and who know what it is
but
the way things like automl work today
here's the workflow it's pretty great
you take data and you put it into some
sort of an automation machine
and then you cross your fingers and hope
that the automation is flexible enough
for the problem that you want to solve
and that there isn't anything unusual or
out of pattern in your particular use
case to to make it where it doesn't work
and then you find out that that of
course isn't true and then you just find
somebody to do it by hand that's how
automl works today for the most part
here's how it should work uh you take
your data you put it into some sort of
automation machine
and that can that does some Automation
and build some stuff but then it gives
you the code for that stuff that it
built so that you can take it and adapt
it to whatever the specifics of your
particular problem should be
unfortunately there are no actual tools
that really seem to do that very well
out there today
and then everybody's happy
so
so this is this is the slide about serve
we won't talk about that but the idea
here is that
okay let me oh that's the last slide
okay so the the idea here is that
um
there are an awful lot of options out
there when it comes to where you develop
your uh your machine learning algorithms
and you have lots of choices when it
comes to what what tools to use some of
them are Mouse based some of them are
keyboard based some are scripting type
environments some are much lower level
some are more exploratory but certainly
I think that the exploratory tools are
necessary to do data science because you
have to have that sort of iterative kind
of process where you're able to explore
see what the data looks like and so on
and that's not straightforward at least
it's not convenient in most scripting
and software engineering type tools so I
think a unique tool set needs to be
developed for data scientists that is
code based but also really interactive
that also is stable enough to actually
be useful in a a production type
environment and I don't think any of
those tools except serve have been have
been built yet so it's it's actually
really interesting there's been a huge
amount of innovation on both sides Mouse
based and keyboard based but they're all
sort of missing the boat in terms of
hitting all three of those check boxes
Deployable interactive and also you know
complete so that's all I had we have 10
minutes or so left for questions
and you can completely disagree with me
those are the most interesting type of
questions so
Greg at least for me it was very
familiar having
[Music]
that to work with this solution
um are there any uh questions from the
room
yeah
I'll come to you at the microphone so
the people online can also hear it
thanks to the talk yeah I'm very
familiar as well lots of the issues
um
do you think there's a space for
individual tools which solve part of the
problem or do you think it should be an
all-encompassing complete solution maybe
maybe you've already said you think it
should be complete but maybe talk about
the trade-offs there
I think that what you see with most
vendors is that there's a a deep desire
amongst vendors to keep you in their
tool in their platform and so you end up
kind of stuck unless the platform is
perfect and none of them are right so uh
so then you have sort of I think most
people when you ask them what tech stack
they use in the in data science anyway
they'll say things like well some of
everything right like we use some
notebooks and we've got you know and the
more sophisticated they are the more
they've moved toward a system that is
relatively inflexible and but really
good at the specific stuff that they
need to do
um so I think I think what you need I
think the key to having a winning
toolkit in the data science space is one
that will allow you to do what you need
to do inside it or to pull what you need
out of it and move into some other tool
so certainly that's one of our values
and what we're building is that wherever
you are in the process you can suck out
all of your stuff from from zerv and put
it into whatever else you need in order
to get what you're doing done so I think
the flexibility is the most important
thing but everybody's going to try to
build that end-to-end ecosystem
which I think
is probably a bad idea
anyway that's my opinion
yeah other question
so why not teach people to code better
[Laughter]
question uh why why aren't data
scientists better coders I guess is the
question
um
yeah I mean right
yeah uh they should be I should be we
all should be better coders but you sort
of work with what you have I guess uh
certainly in the uh what we've seen is
that
organizations kind of have who they have
in terms of resources and one option
would certainly to be to fire those guys
and hire machine learning Engineers
which would be great for machine
learning Engineers because salaries
would go way up right because how many
of them are there really uh but on the
other hand
there is a I think there's a balance
right you need the guys that can open
notepad and from from scratch you know
pull in data from uh you know I don't
know some obscurious Hive say some some
crazy Hadoop system and just using a
text editor and then and then uh you
know code up the algorithm for gradient
boosting from scratch and oh and also do
that uh and and save that model out and
then put it in some production yeah
maybe you need that
um but I think there's there are also a
type of data scientists that are
um more sort of exploratory that focus
more like on the art side and maybe more
on the science side than on the coding
side and there's I think there's always
going to be sort of a give and take
between those two guys or gals
um
and I think they both sort of bring some
fun to the party I'll give you an
example there's a guy named Sergey
Jurgensen who was a number one kaggler
you guys know what kaggle is yeah okay
all right I forgot I forgot where I am
nobody knows where what kaggle is but he
was number one for two or three years
and there was this one project where it
was like it was using uh telescope data
this is one of the competitions he won
to
um
to classify star types or something it
was some obscure astronomy thing of
course he's not an astronomer he doesn't
know anything about astronomy but in
looking at the data he happened to
notice this one little pattern in the
data set
that gave him an edge over everybody
else so today kaggle is the kaggle is
only about finding Target leakage at
this point so it's it's not fun anymore
it's been broken but back then he found
this one really interesting feature that
had nothing to do with coding and
everything to do with oh I just got in a
notebook and I just started playing
until I found something that was really
interesting Sergey can't he can't do the
airflow stuff like he can't he can't
build a machine learning pipeline but
most of those guys can't find what he
found right so it's I think it's about
different skill sets and kind of like
you know diversity and all that jazz
I don't know that's a rambling answer
but we should all be better coders
it's my way of saying I don't want to be
a better coder shut up
uh anyone else who has a question yeah
do you know a guy named Thomas Whitehead
you look exactly like him it's weird
never heard of him okay
so why don't you like databricks because
I heard you saying something about it
yeah you know the last time I said that
somebody asked me the same question and
I may be uh so I may be out of date on
data breaks I haven't looked at
databricks in like a few years but it's
my experience that it's super hard to
get started with those guys
uh that it takes that that uh the
learning curve for me was super Steep
and very annoying uh and they don't have
a free product so I think that any good
tool in the space needs a valuable
always free product and so anytime I see
like a 14-day trial I really really
don't like that
uh and then also it may not be the case
anymore but databricks is kind of an all
always on kind of thing so I think the
compute cost on databricks is pretty
high as well so I don't know it could it
could be a good tool I don't have deep
experience in data bricks I mostly just
like to be controversial so
thanks I mean they're worth what are
they worth now 40 billion or something
you know like
look at me databricks sucks huh
so thanks for the talk uh at some point
you mentioned so uh IPython jupyter
notebooks uh those started as an open
source project and the fact that today
we have so many vendors who came up with
their own solution does it mean that at
some point we missed an opportunity in
the open source world to draw like specs
and a standard that people could have
followed instead of like having everyone
build their own source that's a I
actually love that question uh
this is an example of why open source is
hard I think I don't know how in a
I don't know how in a with a tool
or in an open source kind of development
environment you make such a deep
architectural change
to like get rid of the restart kernel
button like I don't think that's
possible like even if you had a thousand
people who wanted to do that I'm not
sure how you would make that that happen
in in an open source project where
you've got lots and lots of contributors
maybe that could totally happen it's
possible
we preserve we decided not to be open
source but to have a free product
um
yeah I like the open source Community
but a lot of times the
uh the people that are organizing these
open source tooling they're they're
trying to actually build a company so if
you look at companies like uh anybody
use Ray Ray's like uh distributed
compute kind of thing Bray is built and
uh maintained by a company called uh any
scale and they have a uh commercial
product
which is as far as I can tell exactly
the same as the open source product so
this kind of Open Source uh databricks
was actually did really well with open
source right spark is open source
databricks built a differentiated
product that's significantly different
and better than than the open source
product a lot of companies that start
out as an open source
program or project don't and so there's
not much differentiation in the end of
struggling
but at the same time they do Advance the
open source community so I don't know if
I answered your question I just rambled
for
five minutes uh yes maybe just a quick
follow-up maybe to to narrow things down
yeah it's not really more about the
product itself but read more about the
specifications you know nowadays you
want to design a rest API or a graphql
API you need photo specifications same
thing goes with I don't know designing a
database you have to abide by specific
words
as the designer of a new product in the
notebook space do you feel like it would
have been easier to start from like a
set of like well-known specifications
taken from like the lessons of many
previous iterations instead of like
starting not really from scratch but
almost like having like some kind of
Baseline reference
um so we I could speak Reserve I mean we
certainly came in with an opinion about
what we think was needed uh we we we
definitely have views about about that
and we really are building on kind of
what Jupiter started in in a lot of ways
even though we didn't actually use any
of their code
uh any of the open source projects when
we when we built what we built
um
yeah I don't know I guess it depends on
the project
any other questions I cannot answer
laughs
yeah thank you for your talk it's very
interesting and I can relate because I
also work in clinical trials and I work
with stars nice my condolence you know
what SAS stands for I'm not I'm
currently playing do you know what SAS
stands for yeah no actually semicolon
always semicolon
I just were wondering how do you propose
to how what's your vision to address the
screenshot issue so I mean after
listening to the talk about
um like databasization storytelling
anyway the decision makers didn't want
your notebook at the end they want
PowerPoint or something like that so how
what's your vision what we do in serve
is we automate the creation of the
slides so we you can dump slides
directly out of serve uh into PowerPoint
so there
he he audibly groaned he's like oh my
yeah
uh like it or not PowerPoint is the
language of business and there are an
awful lot of app companies that have
come along uh that like like
um uh shoot what is that one that uh
oh I'm out of time we had we have a
little bit of time
oh God
they're they're an awful lot of
companies out there that are like we can
you can build apps with us really fast
like none of them I can't think of the
names of any of them off the top of my
head but there's tons of mountains of
them
um and you know nobody's using them no
CEO or business leader is going to log
into an app to look at stuff right
they're good
yeah why don't you he's your said than
done you certainly you certainly could
do it it's not hard to push into
PowerPoint it's hard to push out of
PowerPoint is the problem so maybe a
slides integration would be a Google
Slides integration would be a little bit
easier but um and there's a company that
I saw called Equals I think and they're
trying to build a Google Slides
competitor uh which might be worth a
Google I haven't looked into them at all
but the approach that we're taking is to
to make it really easy to automate the
creation of slides so that you never
have to actually go in and copy and
paste and that sort of thing
download is Powerpoint exactly yeah
that's that's what the button says
actually
so maybe we're part of the problem
well I'm questioning everything now
okay so more questions thanks it was
yeah very relatable
um more questions on the features or how
you're thinking out stuff
about the GitHub or slack email sharing
of not Google how do are you thinking
about that because uh we are keeping our
notebooks in GitHub and we are actually
reviewing the awful uh you know Jason's
yeah yeah
um yeah yeah so we suffer that and I
think I saw some kind of GitHub play in
order but it's a paid one extremely
expensive for what it does it seems
simple maybe it's not yeah uh I don't
know exactly how Jupiter work Jupiter
notebooks work under the hood but every
time I've ever tried to put one in
GitHub they're always change uh like
there's some metadata or something in
there maybe it's a time stamp or
something what's that
okay well something like yeah that's
probably it it's impossible right so
um what we do in serve is we integrate
with GitHub uh just by just the code and
the metadata separately so uh yeah I'm
happy to talk to you about that later
but all right yeah yeah
we also do version history inside the
app so we're trying to to do like a
Google Docs kind of version history type
thing inside the app but I recognize
that's not some people want to want to
have pull requests and that sort of
thing
anyway
well thank you all for uh the questions
please give Greg a round of applause
[Applause]